es momento de nuestra revista de prensa
en el France 24 aquí en directo América
y abrimos en nuestra sección hablando de
Venezuela porque allí continúa la
apertura de diplomática del gobierno de
Nicolás maduro con distintas naciones
desde la consolidación del
restablecimiento de las relaciones con
Colombia hasta un distintivo encuentro
con su homólogo francés en el marco de
la cop 27 en Egipto como se reporta esto
Pues nos lo cuenta a Marta Moya y Marta
cómo nos lo dicen en los medios
nacionales el tiempo por ejemplo habla
del tema Buenos días Ángela Pues así es
empezamos con un medio colombiano el
tiempo que titula aterrizó el primer
vuelo desde Venezuela hacia Colombia
luego de casi tres años concretamente
dos años y ocho meses seis días después
del encuentro entre Nicolás maduro y
Gustavo Petro en Caracas uno de estos
objetivos de la reunión era también la
resolución cidotextualmente de nudos
críticos en materia de transporte y esto
se terminó de consolidar ayer con el
primer vuelo que volaba desde Venezuela
hasta Bogotá donde nos encontramos esta
este esta aerolínea turpial Airlines va
a operar dos vuelos a la semana lunes y
sábados con boletos bastante caros la
verdad hasta 500 dólares por otra parte
la aerolínea satena colombiana pondrá la
venta boletos por 900 o sea por 299
dólares esta noticia se ha hecho esperar
y se ha en al menos dos
ocasiones desde el 26 de septiembre que
es cuando estaba previsto que se diera
el primer vuelo efectivamente Están
carísimos pero pues no podíamos esperar
nada diferente también habla sobre el
tema El mercurio de Venezuela Así es
Ángela y titula vamos a cambiar de tema
porque hablamos también de esta apertura
como decíamos diplomática y se refiere
al encuentro entre Nicolás maduro y
Emmanuel macron su homólogo francés en
el día de ayer en Egipto en el marco de
la Cup Esta bueno este breve encuentro
se dio en los pasillos en
Shake y bueno es un paso importante
sobre todo después de que
Francia rompiera relaciones con
Venezuela en 2019 cuando macron
reconoció a Juan guaidó como presidente
encargado ayer ambos se reunieron y
macron llamó presidente a Nicolás maduro
y además acordaron reunirse después de
la Copa Bueno lo simbólico que es que
los vean Juntos por los pasillos de la
cop 27 también hay titular del país Así
es Y es que bueno además de esta
apertura
diplomática el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro ha cerrado 79 emisoras de radio
en lo que va de 2022 una medida tomada
por la Comisión Nacional de
telecomunicaciones que ha afectado a mil
trabajadores una medida de 8 emisoras al
mes las estaciones afectadas son
principalmente regionales y el modus
operandi es que el gobierno no renueva
las licencias que se vencen este
artículo del país cita a una ong que se
llama espacio público que dice que entre
2003 y 2022 se han cerrado por el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro 233 emisoras
muy bien Vamos a cambiar de tema porque
hoy es el día en el que los
estadounidenses salen a votar en sus
elecciones de medio término por los
legisladores gobernadores estatales y
otros regidores locales que dice la
prensa internacional sobre este tema
Marta y vamos a empezar con el diario
punto es José Ángela vamos a empezar
destacando un mensaje de ayer del ex
presidente Donald Trump que dijo que
probablemente anunciará su candidatura a
la presidencia de Cara a las elecciones
de 2024 El próximo 15 de noviembre esto
se refiere a un acto que hizo ayer en
Ohio donde se refirió ayer en el cierre
de campaña y estuvo apoyando a los
candidatos republicanos y dijo que el
próximo 15 de noviembre en mara lago en
su residencia en Florida están
convocados a un gran mitin para hacer un
gran anuncio cito textualmente Aunque
Ayer ya se preveía que a lo mejor podía
anunciar esta candidatura no lo hizo
pero sí que empleó frases como en 2024
vamos a recuperar nuestra magnífica
Casablanca o éramos una gran nación y
volveremos a hacerlo y ahora también el
portal Alfa
así es y es un tema muy interesante
porque el fired hace un análisis sobre
que el 60% de los estadounidenses van a
encontrar hoy en sus papeletas a
candidatos que negaron las elecciones de
2020 concretamente dice el portal que de
los 552 candidatos republicanos que se
presentan hoy a las distintas elecciones
199 han negado por completo las
elecciones de 2020 61 han negado
parcialmente las elecciones y que además
116 de ellos y 8 que han negado
parcialmente tienen un 95 por ciento de
posibilidades de ganar las elecciones
hoy y eso nos habla también un poco del
peso de esta toma del Capitolio del 6 de
enero sobre estas elecciones y
finalmente del país el país destaca otro
análisis que dice los referéndums clave
en las elecciones de medio mandato en
Estados Unidos aborto marihuana y
esclavitud y es que como comentábamos
antes en los noticieros hoy no solo se
eligen a legisladores sino que además
los estadounidenses al menos en 36
estados votarán en distintos referendos
para dilucidar cuestiones como el aborto
los impuestos a la posesión de armas o
abolir los últimos reductos de la
esclavitud el aborto se votará en cinco
estados no todos con la misma premisa
por ejemplo en Estados más demócratas se
votará si se protege en Estados más
republicanos y se tiene que prohibir
definitivamente la marihuana se va a
votar en otros cinco estados a ver si se
permite su uso recreativo y la
esclavitud aunque fue abolida ya en 1863
no fue excluida de las de los cargos en
las prisiones no de esos castigos en las
prisiones y hoy este 8 de noviembre
también se va a votar en cinco estados
sí finalmente se termina de abolir la
esclavitud muy bien Vamos a cerrar en
Egipto con el otro gran tema que hemos
venido manejando en nuestros noticieros
el medio está ahí reportó qué
periodistas locales iniciaron una huelga
de hambre en Solidaridad con los presos
políticos enmarcado en la Cumbre Pues
por el clima de las Naciones Unidas
Aprovechando que el foco Mundial de la
prensa internacional está Precisamente
en Egipto estos días profesionales de la
prensa local se han declarado en huelga
de hambre para protestar sobre todo por
el encarcelamiento de a la el fatag que
es un periodista que fue icónico en la
revueltas egipcias de 2011 en esa
Revolución egipcia y desde en los
últimos 10 años este periodista que
lideró esa revuelta ha estado ocho en
prisión concretamente en 2019 y 2021
también volvió a ser preso por publicar
noticias falsas en un juicio que a todas
luces la comunidad internacional ha
valorado como que vulnera los Derechos
Humanos pues Marta Gracias por hacernos
este paneo nos deja bien informados y
ahora vamos con el invitado del día
gracias